Après plusieurs années en couple
Ouais, j'ai une certaine experience de la vie.
- je me rends compte qu'il y a certaines filles qui sont quand même plus jalouses que d'autres.
Sauf que maintenant je connais le responsable de 99% des embrouilles de couple liées à la jalousie :
C'est lui.
"Salut, je suis un téléphone !"
Voilà c'est cette connerie
et même si t'es un mec sage, un mec fidèle
Il y a toujours une photo ou un message qui peut être mal interprété.
C'est qui cette grosse pute dégueulasse et vulgaire qui est avec toi sur la photo ?!
Bah, c'est toi ça...
...Ah ouais, c'est ma robe.
Ah ouais c'est vulgaire !
On dirait Conchita Wurst !
Je crois qu'il y a certains textos qu'il ne faut surtout pas recevoir quand tu es en couple.
Notamment ce fameux :
""Tu fais quoi ?" message recu à 2H du matin par un numéro inconnu, tu m'expliques ?"
"Peut-être que c'est un pote qui veux faire un foot..."
"À 2h du matin...?!"
"Tu me dégoute, taré !"
"Oh pourquoi il répond pas ?"
"Je vais pas faire un foot tout seul moi."
Enfin il y a pire, je crois que le truc qui rend le plus hystérique une meuf au monde,
c'est quand tu reçois un texto devant elle, mais que tu le lis pas.
ça mon gars, c'est grave.
"Bah pourquoi tu lis pas ton message ?"
"Bah je sais pas je le lirai plus tard."
"Bah non vas-y lis le !"
"Ben c'est bon, j'ai pas envie de le lire, je suis pas obligé de le lire ça va !"
"Mais tu te fous de ma gueule ou quoi, t'as un truc à cacher ? Tu le lis maintenant sinon je te quitte !"
"Bouygue vous informe que votre forfait..."
"Avec une photo de ses seins ?"
"Ah bon ?"
Je te jure je deviens ouf.
Parfois j'ai tellement peur que ma meuf fouille mon portable et trouve des trucs chelou
que j'emporte mon téléphone avec moi partout, dans toutes les pièces de la maison.
"Bon je vais prendre ma douche, à tout' !
- Avec ton iPhone ?
- Bah ouais !
- Et ton iPad...?
- Et ton ordinateur portable.
- Bah ouais !
- Et la box internet.
- Ouais.
- Et le câble Ethernet.
- Bah ouais.
- Et ton disque dure externe.
- Bah ouais !
- Et ton casque audio.
- Bon,  écoute quand je vais prendre ma douche j'aime bien être un petit peu connecté !
- Ça te pose problème ?
-Génération Y !
-PUTAIN !"
Bon et puis je sais pas si j'ai la poisse ou quoi
mais moi dès que je tombe par pur hasard sur photo un peu ambigüe
c'est précisément a cette seconde que ma meuf débarque.
"Hey, salut ma chérie ça va ?
- Salut ! Tu regardes quoi là ?...!
- Oh je suis sur Facebook, je traîne tranquille, des petites photos de paysages, je regarde le Sahara, la montagne...
- Alors tu as passé une bonne journée ou pas ?
- Non mais tu te fous de ma gueule en plus ?!
- Comment ça "je me fous de ta gueule" ?
Je suis tranquille, pourquoi tu m'agresses comme ça, je suis décontracté !
- Est-ce que tu as passé une bonne journée ?
- Norman faut qu'on parle
- Pourquoi tu veux toujours parler ? En permanence tu veux toujours parler de tout ! Y'a pas de problème !
- C'est pas possible ça, j'aime bien la forêt, je regarde la forêt !"
Moi y'a des question auxquelles j'ai jamais su répondre,
hein de peur de la vexer ou de la rendre jalouse.
Je parle évidemment de ce genre de questions :
"Tu peux me dire si je suis plus grosse ou moins grosse qu'elle ?"
LA QUESTION PIEGE
Bon déja il faut surtout pas être sincère
"Hm, franchement, t'es un peu plus gosse ouais."
CLAC
Ni mitigé
"Bah franchement t'es pareille."
"Je suis aussi grosse que ce tonneau ?!"
"Ouais !" (CLAC)
Ni mentir
"Nan franchement t'es moins grosse"
"En plus tu mens ?!"
Ni être hésitant
"Huuum ouais ça dépend"
"Non mais en plus t'en profite pour mater ? Non !" (aïe)
Ni faire divertion
"Hum OH UN HÉLICOPTÈRE !"
"Où ça ?!"
"Norman tu reviens ici !"
Quand t'es avec ta meuf dans la rue dans un café
Tu peux pas regarder une autre fille
Tu vois c'est normal ça va la rendre jalouse
Bon, à moins d'utiliser une petite technique
"Pourquoi tu regardes cette fille comme ça ? Tu veux son numéro là ou quoi ?"
Technique !
"Bah non pas du tout !"
"C'est juste que je la trouve tellement vulgaire"
"C'est vrai ?"
"Ah ouais, des gros seins avec un gros décolleté
Franchement c'est indécent !"
"C'est vrai que ça fait un petit peu pétasse."
"Franchement elle a cru qu'avoir une peau bien bronzée comme ça , ça allait être stylé ?"
"N'importe quoi !"
"ça me rassure que t'aimes pas les filles comme ça !"
"Tu sais quoi ça m'a dégoûté , j'ai envie de me barrer d'ici
Je me casse illico !"
Voilà pourquoi il faut toujours être
Sincère
Authentique
Honnête
Fidèle
Franc
Et toujours dire la vérité
à celle qu'on aime
"Oh un hélicoptère !
- Arrête !
Mais il y a vraiment un hélicoptè.. - Arrête Norman !"
"Ok j'arrête"
"Mais il y a quand même un hélicoptère. - Tt !"
Mon spectacle Norman sur scène reprend à Paris au Palace à partir du 15 octobre
Vous pouvez commencer déjà à réserver vos places en suivant les sortes de petites flèches qui clignotent
Sur votre écran
Franchement ça va être des barres
Franchement !
Et rien que j'y pense je te jure ça va être trop des barres !